welcome back the biden administration is
set to meet with members of the chinese
communist party later this week in
alaska
it will be the first face-to-face
meeting with the ccp since
president biden took office the
communist regime has been testing
president biden from day one starting
with sanctioning trump officials like
former secretary of state mike pompeo
marching into hong kong and bullying its
neighbors in the south china sea
china's end game overtaking america as
the world's leading superpower
and it will do whatever it takes to make
that happen the only question
does joe biden have what it takes to
make them stop
joining me right now to talk more about
that is republican senator from arkansas
tom cotton and senator it's always great
to see you
thank you for being here tonight what do
you anticipate
about this upcoming meeting between the
biden administration and the ccp members
well i hope that secretary of state tony
blinken and the national security
adviser jake sullivan
will draw a very hard line in alaska and
i hope that it's not a very hospitable
trip
for their chinese counterparts and those
chinese communists go back to beijing
very disappointed about america's
bipartisan resolve to stand up to
beijing but i have to say maria based on
a series of
early missteps or hesitancies or mixed
messages i'm not
confident that that is going to be the
result of this meeting in alaska later
this week
well you have been uh very uh
smart and vocal about many things
regarding the chinese communist party
you were the first one to come on
my program in 2020 to explain exactly
uh how the coronavirus
was allowed to leave the chinese borders
and inflict the entire world i have not
heard president biden discuss the
origins of the coronavirus have you
no i haven't either maria that'd be a
very good uh
first item on the agenda in alaska is to
demand
that beijing come clean about what
happened in wuhan and allow
an international team of scientists to
include americans to visit the institute
of virology in wuhan and have total
and uncontrolled access to its personnel
so even if they've destroyed the
evidence we can at least take
the statements of people who were there
that's not what the world health
organization did last month and they
sent a team
in basically just to corroborate the
chinese story
that's just one thing though that should
be on the agenda item we should press
them on
their uh breaking their words and their
international commitments on hong kong
autonomy
and the genocide they're perpetrating
against religious and ethnic minorities
in western china
these are things that some biden
administration officials have raised
either in speeches or congressional
testimony but joe biden himself
has been very reticent to push china on
those issues and that's not a strong
signal
to send to chinese to china's leader xi
jinping
what should the u.s be doing about this
i mean
i certainly remember hong kong to be an
amazing
international business hub where
you felt that there was freedom you
certainly felt that there was
opportunity
i understand from my sources in hong
kong it is a
very bleak time right now in hong kong
should the u.s be responding
to how the ccp has handled things
yeah it's a terrible tragedy maria hong
kong has a vibrant
history of freedom and democracy and the
rule of law
and china committed to uphold that for
50 years in 1997 when they reclaimed
sovereignty over hong kong from the
united kingdom
and not even a quarter of a century into
that commitment
they broke it and they were pressing all
hong kongers now china should have to
pay
for all of these transgressions whether
it's violating its commitments about
hong kong
or committing genocide against its own
people or stealing our jobs and our
property
and using them to try to outpace us as
the world's economic
leader now how they pay for that is up
for us
so for instance one thing i've pressed
our generals on and our admirals on
in the armed service committee as of
late is that we need to be deploying as
many
ground-based missiles as possible to our
territories in the western pacific and
our allies
to hold china at risk they haven't faced
that for a long time
because we were constrained in an old
and outdated treaty with russia
but put a few hundred or more likely a
few thousand missiles in the western
pacific that can reach the chinese
mainland and will make the leaders in
beijing sweat a lot
we also have not heard president biden
say much about the uyghurs
and the genocide that is being committed
there so
we'll see if this comes up in this
meeting but i want to get your take on
the upcoming olympics there is uh
uh the olympics happening in uh 2022
and gordon chang tweeted this a friend
asked
will china collect dna samples
of the athletes and others at the
olympics if they are held in beijing
and he says you bet do you think that
the chinese communist party will collect
dna of our athletes
well i wouldn't put it past the chinese
communist party to undertake any kind of
spying or espionage against americans in
beijing
i think the international olympic
committee needs to try to move these
olympics out of china
they were awarded under different
circumstances when so many people still
took the china threat for granted
um and if barring that then i think we
need to seriously consider senator
romney's proposal
that we have an economic and diplomatic
boycott even if we send our athletes
athletes to compete americans don't go
to watch they don't spend money in
hotels and restaurants and sightseeing
american corporations don't sponsor
these games so hit china where it hurts
on these olympics in their pocketbook
but there needs to be consequences for
china's malign
actions not only against american
interest but against international peace
and stability more broadly
and its brutal repression of its own
people now let me ask you before you go
senator you are on the front lines in
terms of ensuring
that we have the agenda that will
lead to progress in america you've got
hr1
you've got a 1.9 trillion stimulus
you've got another package on the way
that's coming
including higher taxes a word about this
agenda
how do you see it
well i think it's a failed agenda it's a
radical agenda joe biden is simply
the front man for the far democratic
left that wants to spend trillions of
dollars
on their long-standing priorities wants
to rig the rules of our elections wants
to use
your tax dollars to elect democratic
candidates wants to pack the supreme
court and wants to make washington d.c
estate it's not popular and they're not
going to do it
can you do anything about it to stop it
well right now they don't have the votes
to pass it because it's so unpopular if
they've got divisions in their own party
they can't even pass most of these
things
through the house of representatives
much less the senate
all right senator it's good to have you
this evening thanks very much we will
catch up soon
senator tom cotton